police and military officers out in
force in Benghazi with the city's
residents heading to the polls there
have been deadly clashes here between
militants and security forces but Libyan
authorities are pressing on with the
elections they've declared a public
holiday to encourage people to get to
the polls and cast their vote the
elections are the only way forward for
the country and a route to safety
Libyans hope the polls will bring
stability many feel the interim
leadership hasn't done that but nivelle
cut the next parliament must take into
account Libyans feelings and serve
Libyans not like the general National
Congress they forgot about the Libyan
people and their feelings mashhad in
libby the previous assembly became
paralyzed by political infighting
lawmakers in the general National
Congress had sought to extend their
mandate until December but the election
is gone ahead amid public pressure un
representatives in Tripoli say they're
satisfied with how the election process
has been organised initial results are
expected later in the week